with the San Jose Barracuda this season in the
American Hockey League he played briefly there
last year here's aoso coming back with a backhand
bit that's stopped by Capo kakenan the Buffalo Ned
Justin Bailey but then it's Stripped Away From
Him Eric Robinson now for Buffalo Hill waight
put it on net playing for the rebound with Zack
Benson the sabes have always been a tough matchup
for the San Jose Sharks in fact no team has had
a higher points percentage against San Jose then
Buffalo over the years power up on the right Point
side Savers Casey midat he's their leading score
oh and power and that's knocked down by kinan as
we settle in here in this first period no score
Robinson had a couple of looks earlier on his last
chter or two ago over to clipon the former bu save
by Ken rebound pick back up by the Sabers it's
Benson out of the corner work for declair couldn't
catch it and turning back with it is Ryan Johnson
he's chased down by Alexander barabanov who one of
the stars of the night on Tuesday for the Sharks
here's Pon takes a hit to Muk asz he got the clap
to the side of the net back home after this hoping
to be two and one from California they've split so
far between the Ducks and Kings Peta on the right
wing and King it with a save off Dylan cousins we
need to pop some ammonia caps down there on
the bench remind the guys the game started at
one well I tell you what got to give the other
team credit every once in a while bu sa should
started on China David Quinn kind of reminded
his guys exactly that there you go there you go
right on Q Mark Edward blasic gives the Sharks
the lead on just their second shot of the day
well you ask and you shall receive Mark Edward
blassic jumps in on this play just get Puck to
the net right sometimes it's just that simple Puck
goes around a terrific job by Nico Stern being and
erson who has to puck now and build here's sing
nice dangle that's the shot away and Lucan with
the save barabana has it back beats one man then a
second Reaching Across his Clair sends it in front
a chance for barabanov picked up an assist on that
goal by blassic Ruda Far Side wanted stir now Nico
with a Chance on the play it's Tak taken back by
the Sabers Jacob Bryson can't clear and they score
yon Ruda with the shot deflected on its way to the
net but it's his goal good work on the four check
getting some help three guys versus three guys
the Sharks continue to work after it good Third
Man by William eckan you've got to have a good
third man that way everybody can stay in and Yan
Ruda because of that play by William eckan just
fires it towards the net and the Sharks take the
two nothing lead that's good after being shot out
in Buffalo 12 days ago three nothing and he was
just getting out all those snow drips through
has a lot to do with it here's Justin Bailey
the Buffalo native burrows for the Sharks got to
get to the net cut off on his way there by Jacob
Bryon number 78 for the Sabers now was covered by
hurdle behind the net middle stat Cuts in checked
by Zin a onetime by Hopman and Lucan there comes
up with the save [Applause] territory cousin big
season last year a big new seven-year contract
to go with it stck on just nine goals this year
but he's been better lately comes off a good game
in La cousin does as power go short Sid gra round
bit and they score It's JJ petka right on Q and
the sabers get one back and shoot a one so hard
work along the fors keep the puck in as the Gman
travels down the key on this play is that Copo
tries to get over and look at everybody everybody
slides to the man coming from behind the net you
get behind the net cousins does a nice job finds
peterka but you get behind the net that changes
everything cuz the vision goes from looking up
I looking at where the puck is they're having
now turn around and can't see the front penalty
and was a plus four on the night stops this one
fires it out towards tuck now py and that one hit
the post Justin Bailey a chance to counter attack
here if they get organized and they do sadet to
hurdle toas to sadet he wanted to bump that back
out in front Hoffman was there he gets a whack
at it anyway and Uka lcan and finally able to
get his glove out on it go to f barracuda.com for
more here's William ekland he's assisted on both
sharks goals here's bling and up with some kind
of save off classic defensively as you're talking
about good drive right up through the middle
Mark glassic takes the slash goes to the back
hand looking it with a really nice save we talked
about him before when he stretches out it's hard
to get the puck around him he's a big midle stat
goes deep to the corner Bailey battle with midle
stat and now the Sabers score Jordan Greenway
ties it up the Savers with great work along the
boards and they finally got the goal and it's two2
it's just working working for the goal good work
along the boards sharks are good position want
to squeeze up here but they work their way off
the boards and then it becomes a 2-11 out fight
in that situation you probably like to see the
forwards collapse a little harder not to take
away that two-on-one situation but it's just
the work ethic along the boards getting off the
boards first and not a quick enough reaction to
collapse to the net when there was trouble but
the Sharks did it twice against Rivals do the
kings here's a turnover Casey mdal stat it into
the slot and top scores and the Sabers have come
come all the way back to take the [Applause]
lead coming back up through the middle sharks
look like they're okay could be out of the zone
and unfortunately Nik STM puts it back to the
middle middle stack grabs it Green Wave sets
up in front for the screen really good screen
and Shakir has to go with his man and there
again is that turn shot hard to find and on
a tried to go back hand with aure now a
hook you that one got through but it's
wide and it's right into the path of Twinn
cousins on the wing they score JJ petera
again that's his second of the game backto back
two goal games for the German forward it's 42
Buffalo but the shot misses goes wide comes
back out the other way three on two just a
pass across beautifully finished shot it's a
Well executed three on two to you try to delay
the attack as much as possible but arabana front
of the net now moves off to the side you got to
move you can't stall yourself out you got to
move on this positioning by Dylan C then the
move on cure empty net for Dylan cousins to put
this one away maybe 52 moving in this situation
they put themselves into the corner and then
after that it was a nice little play by Dylan
cousins forward on forward and the empty Netter
but the key on the play is that the Sharks had
possession but then they turned themselves
into the small ice you've got to expand the
Zone you've got to start making the at Le and
it'll be another three bow margin of Victory
here this [Music] afternoon a victory for Uka
peka Lucan his record in Cru to 12 11 and two